ليل وايران لا يهدا صرخات المحتاجين
توقظون مدنها مناديه بحياه وحريه في
الاهواز جنوب غربيه ايران خرج المتظاهرون
الى الشوارع هاتفين بالموت للديكتاتور
باشاره الى المرشد علي خامنائي ومنظومته
الحاكمه اما تبريز شمل غربي ايران سكتت
المظاهرات واطلقت الايادي بالتصفيق تنديدا
بقمع النظام للاحتجاجات الشعبيه وفي طهران
العاصمه مركز صناعه قرارات النظام
المواجهه المحتاجين كانت المشاركه التي
باتت لا تنقطع وبالمقابل لم يدخل النظام
باستخدام كافه سبل محاولات القمر
في قوم التي توصف بقلعه المرجعيات
المتحكمه في ايران خرج صوت طالبه جامعيه
مواجهه سؤالا لنائب المدينه في البرلمان
عن سبب اعدام الشاب محسن شكري بتهمه اغلاق
الشارع رد النائب البرلماني بابتسامه دفعت
الطالبه لمطالبته بالخجل امام خطف السلطات
لارواح المحتاجين
ودوليا علاقه سلوك النظام القمعي الذي
يستغل القضاء ايضا ذراعا للبطشي
بالمحتاجين لا قائدناه من مختلف الدول في
معبره الديانه الطحاوي مسؤوله في منظمه
العفو الدوليه عن دار منظمتها حيل قرار
قضاء النظام بعدم الشاب محسن شكري بعد اقل
من ثلاثه اسابيع من ادانته في محاكمه
سوريا ظالمه وفقه قولها حنان المصري
العربي